to fight terrorism the United States and
Europe needs to exchange criminal data
but equally citizens personal
information should be protected this is
the umbrella agreements aim which the
european parliament has at last given
the green light we achieved a lot in the
negotiations to improve the protection
for personnel data in this area of
police and justice in the United States
so there we can now see that we really
get better standards than before before
US citizens could have their criminal
records corrected even in Europe but
Europeans could not do the same in the
US thanks to the umbrella agreement
everyone would at last have the same
rights if you happen to have the same
name as a criminal blacklisted in
America consequences can be severe EU
citizens will be able to have their name
deleted if necessary by a judge once the
mistake is discovered finally data that
changes hands will be restricted to
specific files and to the duration of
the investigation only this is different
in the area of companies a data or of
intelligence services where we still
have to improve quite a lot in the
United States where they are not
comparable to our protection in the
future the standards for the exchange of
criminal data set out in the agreement
could act as a basis for further Accords
relating to trade data or intelligence
services
you